foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
oh the lying frauds that they are
[Music]
told you George Santos was not an
outlier
one's excited that
he dresses up in Drag
Carey Lake listen Kerry Lake was best
friends with people who dressed up Drake
she invited in their home she would
party with them
again
telling you these are not outlying lies
these aren't abnormal lies at the
Republican Party tells that Republicans
in general the American first Nazis tell
the same old [ __ ] different diaper
it really is he just he just he just
takes every single one of them under his
wing every one of the Republican lies
I don't know I don't know exactly who is
George Santos's type we don't really
know that
he claims
and he's not a direct which I don't I
don't have a problem I I think more
members of Congress should dress up and
drag to be frank
I think we should have more members of
Congress who have dressed up than drag
we should definitely have that 100
percent
maybe they wouldn't be attacking people
in marginalized communities
hell I should dress up on and and drag
on the [ __ ] floor and have a show do
it do a dance music why not in Missouri
they're trying to make sure women can't
show their [ __ ] arms
but this is not this is not new
about the drag queen thing
Kerry Lake do you remember this story
and maybe I'll maybe I'll pull the video
but there's a very popular famous drag
queen in Arizona who was one of Kerry
Lake's best friends
hung out they were they were friends
they partied together they went they she
went to her shows
performed at her house
this isn't a noob lie
for republicans
this isn't new
same old [ __ ] different diaper
speaking the same old [ __ ] different
diaper Donald Trump
passed the cognitive test
apparently in his deposition he did not
it was person ex-wife man camera TV
what the [ __ ] he he mistakenly
identified
Eugene Carroll as his ex-wife Marla
Maple then his ex-wife Marla Maples is
his second wife by the way
the wife
that he cheated on with his first wife
when they got divorced and he remarried
you know the Christian thing yeah that
old Christian thing
the sanctity of marriage
and he doesn't he doesn't even know what
Marla Maples looks like
or didn't I can't remember I don't know
person ex-wife man camera TV I don't
know it's not difficult
seems pretty simple to me none it to you
this cognitive test
I think this is a a very big nail in the
coffin in this case for Donald Trump
because this whole defense the entire
time has been oh Eugene Carroll is not
my type well this happened in the 90s
folks
Donald Trump I mean he's a big fat slob
now and he looked but he looked a little
different in the 1990s as did E Gene
Carroll as did everyone I [ __ ] I look
completely different in the 1990s who
didn't look different in the 1990s 30
[ __ ] years ago come on
come on I mean there may be a few people
a lot of money and plastic later but
yeah those are outliers here most people
don't look the same that they did in the
1990s but Donald Trump confused
a picture of Aging Carol
for Marla Maples
and the picture was from the time that
Donald Trump allegedly raped
Eugene Carroll that that is horrible for
his defense
and of course um this deposition is is
rolling out
um Christina aren't that is it it's Haba
Haba is the the attorney I guess
who is not objecting to this deposition
being become public
and not surprising that
Donald Trump's half-wit attorneys are
doing things that are hurting him in the
news he also uh and other grandpa poopy
pants and shitty diaper news he's really
pissed off and he's posting on true
social maybe we'll show that one today
again we showed a couple yesterday that
were very significant
in the documents case where he's telling
on himself and confessing out loud
man but
today's pissed off that the media is
saying you're not having rallies and
[ __ ] what's going on
what's going on you ain't got enough
money to go to rallies can't find anyone
to rent you a space because you won't
pay them what's going on
so he's really mad at the media is
pointing out that he's not actually
campaigning he just he just grifting
right he's really pissed off
that they're pointing out he's grifting
and not campaigning so he's gonna have
massive rallies also
oh man this [ __ ] gay he did a video
you guys remember a diamond and silk
Diamond kicked the bucket
that coveted denying anti-vaxx idiot
didn't get vaccinated got coven and it
killed her yeah that that's
what we've been telling you dumb [ __ ]
she won't listen so [ __ ] it [ __ ] them
but Diamond kicked the bucket
and uh I guess they're gonna have some
sort of [ __ ] funeral or some [ __ ]
I wonder if the vaccine is required or
not
oh man I'm sorry I can't help it I can't
help but there was another story
yesterday that the uh the the state
trooper or police officer I don't
remember I think it's a State Trooper
in Washington state he did a video it
went viral in his patrol car in his last
day because the vaccine mandate was
coming up and he refused to get
vaccinated [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm not having
a five you can't tell me what to do
and he told the governor Inslee to kiss
his ass
in the video like basically quitting
right
I take this job and shove it I got
covered and died that's what he did he
got covered and he [ __ ] died
good [ __ ] him
you say God damn Tony you're dancing on
graves you damn right I am
look look you can believe all the stupid
[ __ ] you want out on Facebook and all
the stupid [ __ ] now that's being
disseminated on Twitter
about viruses and Anthony fauci and
vaccines and conspiracy theories about
China and all this stupid [ __ ]
but at the end of the day at the end of
the day the people who are dying right
now
from this new variant are people who are
not vaccinated
who more than anything publicly said
[ __ ] your vaccine I'm not taking it I'd
rather die okay good for you good for
you but Donald Trump announces he's
gonna go
to the funeral service of diamond and
he's gonna speak
oh in this video
it is gold oh it's [ __ ] gold folks
this video that he does where he
announces he's gonna go I don't know
give the eulogy for diamond
you think you think he confuses Marla
Maples and Eugene Carroll do you think
he'll confuse diamond and silk
I don't know maybe he will
maybe he won't know which one is which
he probably doesn't know he doesn't know
their real names I don't know their real
names to be quite honest I don't give a
[ __ ] but he doesn't know their real
names
like in this video he keeps saying it
and and it's really weird how they're
putting out these videos like they got
all the time in the [ __ ] world this
guy's not doing anything
he's a lazy piece of [ __ ] anyways he had
all the Time in the World to script this
thing and do different cuts
and this is the best they can do like
this is the best production value in the
script they can get it's [ __ ]
pathetic he just keeps repeating kind of
the same [ __ ] and meanders on he says
Diamond like 1500 times in a matter of
30 seconds
it's really [ __ ] weird
but it appears that he doesn't even know
her actual name
and it appears that he
and he didn't even know the diamond and
silk you know that's the duo he kind of
looks like he's confused I don't know
maybe it's a pattern that's happening
one too many Big Macs I guess that
grease is getting to his skull
oh this [ __ ] gay now we got the uh
debt ceiling happening today everyone's
freaking out today's the deadline
today's that look the treasury the
treasury is uh Yellen is going to do
some Maneuvers to make sure
that we do not default on our debt as
soon as the the deadline when we hit the
debt ceiling and we've done this stupid
[ __ ] before and and you know the first
time we ever really got in a situation
like this was in the 90s
uh so the confusion with the picture of
Marla Maples and Eugene Carroll in the
90s and the debt ceiling fights happened
in the 90s that was really the first
time we got in this situation look folks
well let me let me tell you how the debt
ceiling works and what it is it is
nothing really other than an arbitrary
permission from Congress that we put in
place to have the arbitrary condition
that that ceiling was done all the way
back in this the first World War
under Woodrow Wilson and the reason why
is because he needed money to go to war
he needed money to fight a war and
Congress appropriates money folks
they're the ones who set legislation
that make sure that the federal
government writes a check to the person
that they say they're writing a check to
and the executive branched the treasury
writes the [ __ ] check that Congress
tells them the right okay it's not
complicated and once you appropriate
funds and set things into law there's no
undoing it it's already been done it's
already been negotiated the deal's
already been made those people are gonna
get paid
and that's why they had the debt ceiling
because what they didn't want to do back
then
was give the president of the United
States in the executive branch a blank
check
which believe it or not they pretty much
do have a blank check especially in
today's age because for us the default
on our debt is really [ __ ] dumb this
is stupid [ __ ]
because
when you have the treasury like it is
the revenue pours in a different amount
at different times the same way as the
bills come due at different points at
different times this is really stupid
[ __ ] that we have to [ __ ] explain
this to the American people on how the
[ __ ] money that the government
collects and then pays out works this is
really stupid
most people don't even [ __ ] know that
the debt ceiling has nothing to do with
future spending not a goddamn thing it
has to do with the spending we've
already guaranteed ourselves through our
government by electing our
representatives to go to Capitol Hill
and appropriate funds in the House of
Representatives you stupid bastards
this is not complicated this is like
Schoolhouse Rock type [ __ ]
you don't you don't need to have a super
intelligence or be in a coastal Elite to
understand these things it's not
difficult you pay bills at home right
right you pay [ __ ] bills at home you
use electricity they send you a [ __ ]
bill you use the [ __ ] the internet
they send you a [ __ ] bill you use
your cell phone they send you a [ __ ]
bill and you pay the son of a [ __ ] and
you're not all you're not you don't get
you don't get paid your entire lifetime
salary all at once
most people work by the hour some on
salary but you get paid weekly bi-weekly
some people get paid every month some
people work on commission or they're
self-employed
not all the money comes in at the same
exact time when the money's going out
it's not [ __ ] rocket science it's the
same [ __ ] with the government
saying goddamn thing
when you're doing bills at your kitchen
table or on your [ __ ] internet or on
your your bill pay ePay or whatever it
is it's the same [ __ ]
and the government has a lot of [ __ ]
bills because we the people have elected
representatives that have appropriated
funds that cause those bills
some of those being benefits that go to
the American people
and I'm not just talking about
entitlements oh we went through this
[ __ ] the other day Social Security
Medicare
I'm talking about school funding for
transportation Highway funding
State funding that leaks down into for
for meals for children at school
and on the other side of the coin you
had the bonds that are secured by this
debt you have to make those payments too
and that's where you when you default on
your debt you lose your credit rating
because what the investors are going to
do whether it's here around the world
who are buying these treasury notes
these treasury bills
they're not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] with any
kind of bonds that come due especially
when they when they risk that a band of
[ __ ] terrorist economic terrorists
are gonna hold your government hostage
and they're not going to get paid
so it's gonna affect average Americans
and it's going to infect it it's gonna
in fact affect the investors in the
treasury notes it is not complicated
it's not hard to understand these things
I know wall Street's difficult the stock
market is foreign language Bitcoin
good luck
nfts
even more luck that you have that where
you're trying to figure out who's
laundering money and who's not
but this debt ceiling thing
is not new
appropriating funds and guaranteeing
funding through those negotiations and
that legislation the laws the policies
that the elected officials that we elect
to go represent us to do this thing
they're the ones who decide they've
already done this they've already done
this and the other thing too is uh
forget who was pointing well several
people were pointing it out but I
retweeted one and I think it was Tristan
and tweeted Trump raised the debt
ceiling three [ __ ] times three
[ __ ] times
this isn't some kind of democratic ploy
to increase the debt and the deficit no
it's just to pay the [ __ ] bills
it's just to pay the bills to make sure
we can borrow enough money to pay it and
really we print the money anyways
this is really stupid dumb stuff really
we should get rid of the debt ceiling
fight altogether and they couldn't use
this thing now my guess is my guess is
that that Republicans are just using
this to get on Fox News Republicans are
just using this to set this up to where
in September they can shut down the
government shutting down the government
doesn't have the same effect as not
raising the debt ceiling it doesn't have
the same effect it's different
I mean different some people are
affected in the same way but it's a
different thing
when the government shuts down as
opposed to
the debt being [ __ ] defaulted on
not being able to pay the debt when the
government shuts down you just you just
stop doing services so you're not
getting bills right you just cut your
you cut your [ __ ] cable off right
it's a little more complicated than that
but that's pretty much it
listen to me they're going to shut down
the government
they're Republicans are scumbags they're
vile pieces of [ __ ] they're gonna hold
our economy hostage because they think
it's going to win them something in 2024
by blaming it on Joe Biden
as if he controls the House of
Representatives and what they do on the
continuing resolution
I mean he can negotiate he can negotiate
future spending there but he can't
negotiate future spending it's already
been negotiated with the debt ceiling
look at it this way the debt ceiling
fight is is Appropriations and money and
bills we've already racked up the
continuing resolution to keep the
government open is future [ __ ]
foreign
s
really can negotiate on the government
staying open they can they're gonna try
to cut your [ __ ] they're gonna try to
take your [ __ ] benefits that you paid
for that you've earned
away from you
that's what they're trying to do
and they're just using this debt limit
thing as a as a as a [ __ ] practice
run of how they're gonna blame Joe Biden
because that's what they want because
they don't give a [ __ ] about you they
don't give a [ __ ] about the government
they don't care how much debt they don't
give a [ __ ] about the deficit they don't
give a flying [ __ ] about no debt ceiling
they don't give a [ __ ]
it's all about how they can use a
[ __ ] manufactured crisis to develop a
narrative so that way they can lie to
their constituents
and they can continue to get elected
based on lies because it is it's a
[ __ ] lie
they're running around talking about
deficits this has nothing to do with it
this is deficits we've already done
dummies and besides the person who
raised the deficit more than any other
president alive is your [ __ ] orange
Mussolini Jesus
Democrats always always got the deficit
every [ __ ] time
every time they get in office
Clinton Obama now Biden
Democrats know how to do the economy
because they I don't know do things
based on reality
not some kind of false ass [ __ ]
narrative that ain't worth the [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] fake just the [ __ ]
manufacture crisis so there are goddamn
constituency stays pissed off about lies
and delusion
foreign
but go try to tell your Uncle Earl that
holy [ __ ]
he knows about as much about the economy
and our government as he knows about
[ __ ] vaccines that's why he's dying
from covid oh
these [ __ ] idiots oh man we just got
to keep marketing them keep going uh the
debt ceiling they're going to do special
accounting today and the thing is you
don't know exactly when the day is that
you're gonna you're gonna default
anyways
because again it's it's kind of
arbitrary of when a bill comes in and
when money comes in to pay that bill
I mean you ever had a bill come due on a
[ __ ] Wednesday but you don't get paid
till Friday yeah that kind of [ __ ] you
know what I mean
you're trying to figure out how you're
gonna swing that two days
that's what the government has to try to
do
and they think they can get their June
or July because we have tax season
coming up so a revenue will pour in in
April
and you know before then as well
but they owe a lot of people a lot of
money too
and some of those returns so they'll be
slow walked
because Republicans
are basing their political strategy on
lies hmm
who knew the party of Santos and Trump
would base their political strategies on
Lies We Will expose those lies here at
the Tony Michaels podcast every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch do me a favor
if you're here on YouTube right now hit
subscribe and if you're on another
platform please come over to YouTube and
subscribe to the YouTube channel we're
trying to get to 20 000 over here on
YouTube
and share with a friend three friends as
a matter of fact see if you can get them
to subscribe to you that would help us
out a lot here at the Johnny Michaels
podcast maybe they'll listen
even your stupid Uncle Earl
who doesn't know how the government
works and is dying from covid because he
didn't get vaccinated because he
believed Facebook the Ivermectin
horse-pace group on Facebook share with
them too why not why not he's got a few
more days left now also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod we're gonna
do the bone end of the week poll today
Thursday because tomorrow's Friday and
you know what happens tomorrow in the
second hour we do bonehead of the week
it is where you vote you decide for
bonehead of the week and then me and my
co-host Gabe Sanchez break it down every
single Friday in the second hour of the
Tony Michaels podcast we even post a
clip over on the Midas Dutch Network so
make sure not to miss the bonehead of
the week pole follow us on Twitter you
can also vote on YouTube that's another
good reason to subscribe you just go
over to the community Tab and that poll
will be there this evening also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google make sure to leave us a great
review
while you're there
Hellboy
I got some video I want to show you got
a couple pictures I want to show you I
got some pictures of George Santos what
appears to be him and drag I'm gonna get
our um
our co-host and Photoshop expert see if
he thinks these things are photoshopped
I can't tell honestly I don't know if
it's a good Photoshop a bad Photoshop
but this is a real photo I have no idea
I don't know
you can't tell with these Republicans
anymore can't separate the lies from the
other lies
even in pictures even if you want to
believe it's the truth I mean Donald
Trump doesn't even know who's who in a
picture how are we [ __ ] supposed to
know right
oh boy oh boy and I think there's some
more more news in the um
the Maga domestic terrorist the um uh
Pena out in New Mexico I believe there's
some new information on that maybe Gabe
Sanchez he's been keeping up on that
maybe he'll give us a an update on that
as well
and I have no fear I don't think your
your debt ceiling is gonna explode today
and but this fight will continue because
Republicans are [ __ ] fake ass frauds
and liars and that's what they like to
do
is lying to the American public just
like Trump likes to lie about who his
type is and who his type isn't
let me ask you
maybe it's I mean maybe maybe not
if you've been married more than once is
it difficult to remember
what your spouses looked like all those
years ago or is this just this just he
has no [ __ ] idea what do you think I
don't know
I guess we'll go through that today in
the [ __ ] let's round up everyone stick
around don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [ __ ]
um
we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
the George Santa's story is heating up
call for him to resign
he's not gonna resign
apparently he is denying
denying the story then he dressed up in
drag now there's a tweet about it we'll
look at it and we're gonna look at some
other stuff on this George Santos
dressing up in drag story again I I
again
it's just a Republican
he's not any kind of special I don't
know I we asked him to resign don't we
have to ask all of them to resign
I mean I'm not opposed to all of them
resigning by any means no that's you
know
but if we ask him don't we have to ask
all of them
to resign I mean really honestly
tell me I'm wrong
tell me tell me I'm wrong
I mean just even in in the first
business that they took care of
Congress is a big [ __ ] lie it's a big
lie a big manufacture crisis like I was
talking about with the debt ceiling and
shutting down the government that they
like to create
they created this entire [ __ ]
narrative this entire [ __ ] lie
during the 2022 midterms that there's
gonna 87 000 IRS agents are going to
show up at your door with guns and
badges and take your guns and your money
and your family or what I don't know
what the [ __ ] I don't know I don't I
don't [ __ ] know
and that they already hired these 87 000
people
and their first order of business was to
fire these imaginary 87 000 people that
didn't work at the IRS
their entire [ __ ] their entire
[ __ ] agenda is based on lies
the old [ __ ] thing
I mean they're they're gonna have a
special Select Committee for the for the
the Biden documents but not the Trump
documents when they're clearly two
different cases there's Criminal Intent
in in the Trump case otherwise the judge
would not have issued the bench warrant
for a search
there's no the reason why there's no
search no search warrant in the Biden
case there was no Criminal Intent
the intent is the most important part
and then the obstruction is the
follow-up
the only thing that ties these two
things together at all is that there's
documents and folders
that are Mark classified but the the
Cheeto dust q and honor
has been selling eating burning
destroying
putting in caskets documents out of
folders We saw this yesterday in his
true social rant
where he's basically admitting to his
crimes
and he's admitting he's telling the
world he's telling us and more more than
importantly he's telling his supporters
what they're going to charge him with
I believe that's what he was doing in
that in those uh posts
apparently too the word is is that he's
begging to get back on Facebook
because true social just isn't doing it
I mean when you're just
sending a message out to a bunch of
[ __ ] bots on your own website
and your your you're fraudulently making
it look like people are interacting with
it it doesn't work very well so he might
end up back on Twitter which folks I
know a lot of people are mad about this
Twitter is already a [ __ ] hellscape
anyways what now I mean elon's totally
ruined this [ __ ] what is going
to be the difference in that schlub
getting back on on [ __ ] Twitter other
than we can [ __ ] with him
ah we can [ __ ] with him imagine all the
[ __ ] we can do and [ __ ] with him on
Twitter
just saying
why are you upset
I mean lib's a tick tock is on Twitter
Michael Flynn is on Twitter now
I mean there's there's just this
dangerous or more dangerous [ __ ] on
Twitter
then that [ __ ] shitty diaper Grandpa
poopy pants yeah get back on Twitter
buddy
we'll [ __ ] with you good on there
yeah boy oh boy it's just fraud after
fraud after fraud lie after lie after
lie I don't know why they want George
Santos to resign
I don't know why
again hey you know I know it's a swing
district and there might be a special
action some of my win blah blah blah
yakety smackity but the thing is is we
get to pin up every single one of these
lines to these idiots who are protecting
him Marjorie Taylor green Matt Gantz
Paul goes aren't these people who got
real committee assignments with real
responsibility
with no accountability
in ethics
they destroyed the Ethics Committee
that's why he's not going to resign
Santos Margaret Xavier green Paul's goes
our or Matt gants really for that matter
Scott Perry there's another one Andy
Biggs
[ __ ] treasonous pieces of [ __ ] and
Chip Roy
the list goes on and on and on
foreign I asked the question yesterday
do we really love pipe Palmers
on the on the homeland security
committee
and the House Representatives do we do
that is that a thing we do in this
country
look pipe bombers domestic terrorists I
mean they're the ones who call
themselves domestic terrorists I don't
want to tell you
I mean again as much as Santos isn't an
outlier in the Republican Party neither
is this guy Pena in New Mexico he's not
that much of an outlier
I mean [ __ ] it appears there's someone
who was planting bombs in Washington
during January 6th
what's the difference in that and paying
500 bucks to a bunch of dumb bucks to go
shoot into a politician's house I mean
really honestly what
could be the difference not that much of
a [ __ ] difference
I mean they said it they said it at CPAC
you know
the molest the Molester Matt schlapp
CPAC
we are all domestic terrorists is what
they said they thought it was really
cute too oh they thought it was
wonderful
okay we're gonna go to the shitlist
Roundup here and I gotta get the egg I'm
gonna ping Gabe Sanchez
see if um see if he's ready or not but I
don't I I'm we're gonna get these images
on here one way or the other
because I got a few questions for him
about this George Santos pictures of him
possibly allegedly and draggy tweeted
about it a moment ago Gabe Sanchez did
um at George Santos if that is his name
let's do this let's round up all the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends the
shitless Roundup right now start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and trendy trends of the day oh boy
I don't know if I was the first of this
one but
made sense to me person ex-wife man
camera TV
ow
you think if he could pass a cognitive
test he could identify a picture
and tell the difference between e Gene
Carroll and Marla Maples now they look
very similar actually
um if you take pictures of when they
were about the same age they look very
similar but he was he was married to one
and it appears allegedly that he raped
the other one I believe e Gene Carroll
whole full-throatedly here especially
since he can't even identify
the difference between her and Marla
Maples
when his entire [ __ ] claim
his entire claim in this case is that
aging Carroll is not his type so you're
telling me
that he married someone who wasn't his
type is that what you're saying Marla
Maples isn't his type is that the claim
he's gonna make now now let's see here
oh here it is
uh hoodlum has it here
uh Trump mistook Aging Care for Marla
Maples when shown a photograph from the
1990s the quote is this this is what he
said this is quote from the deposition
that's Marla yeah that's my wife that's
what he said that's what Trump said
about the picture of e Gene Carroll not
Marla Maples e Gene Carroll
and hoodlum goes on to say here his
blunder quickly corrected by Alina Haba
who told him it was Carol not Maples
Trump has repeatedly used Carol is not
my type as his defense so even Haba that
[ __ ] [ __ ] this this bonehead with
all her shitty legal takes knows the
difference in a photograph from the
1990s of gigin Kara Marla Maples even
she knows but Trump's like yeah sure I
think that's uh I was married and I mean
when I was Mariners with a lot of women
and you know
but yeah that seems to be you know again
person ex-wife man camera TV
oh my God
there's there's
always something
always something
and we're supposed to believe
we're supposed to believe that this
document's case isn't
different between the two
come on
come on
that the everything that he says is the
projection of it
crazy stuff uh let me show you speaking
of his uh statements let me see if I can
find this um
where is it
he had a statement here I thought I'd
[ __ ] retweeted it well son of a [ __ ]
did someone delete that damn thing
Hell Boy
and that Kyle Chaney had it it was the
uh Trump uh uh
true social post
and it's um it's about him going to
rallies he's really butt hurt that the
um that the media
calling him out that he's not having
rallies or big meetings right
he's really pissed off about this here
it is
okay now Kyle does a good job of
pointing it out here Kyle says
prosecutors say the proud boys seditious
conspiracy kicked into gear after
Trump's quote will be wild tweet so it's
fitting that while they're on trial
Trump vows today that his re-election
Campaign Will Be Wild quote and here's
the here's the statement here
now let's see if we can pull this up
where is Gabe's engine okay here we go
Donald Trump says making a big political
speech today at Trump Doral in Miami oh
really big announcement
big announcement he's got to sell more
trading cards he's going to announce
that he definitely won the election it
definitely wasn't stolen he definitely
didn't steal documents to sell eat or
burn
and to cover up his involvement in a
coup attempt on January 6. he definitely
didn't do that
all of it's just keepsakes they're his
documents he's definitely is going to
say that he he Declassified him with his
mind as if that matters and Joe Biden is
the actual criminal rest him not me
because what you're saying I did is what
he did and I'm projecting like a
[ __ ] so that's the speech he's
going to give today
political
ah you self-loathing fat piece of [ __ ]
uh he goes on to say here the fake news
says I am not campaigning very hard
because you're not at all
I mean other than your crashing weddings
at Mar-A-Lago and and and doing your
[ __ ] you're doing your 30 minute bit
that you've been doing for the last six
years and adding to it as you [ __ ]
commit crime
and as we smoke out that crime and you
get exposed for it and then you have to
add some stupid [ __ ] projecting
excuse yeah
if you consider that campaigning
crashing weddings okay yeah sure Grandpa
nice story and he goes on to say I say
they are stupid and corrupt with the
election still a long time away
why did you announce if it's so far away
dummy oh that's right because you're
gonna get indicted and you need to fend
off a trial hmm okay well maybe I'll
explain that here in a minute
he goes on to say but do not fear
many giant rallies in all caps
and other events coming soon other
events and then maybe this is the uh the
diamond silk thing because I told you
that he put out a video that he
announced that he's going to do the
eulogy of someone named Diamond that he
really doesn't even know but was a big
supporter of his and he has to go
he has to go and preach to the choir I
mean really what is he going to do other
than the 30 minutes that he already has
right
I mean he's got 30 minutes that he does
in self-loathing and bitching and
moaning about lies and delusion
what else what else is he gonna say than
what he said in the Diamond video
that he made
he goes on to say it will be wild and
exciting oh I'm sure again this is where
Kyle Chaney was pointing out it's going
to be wild wild and exciting
now here's where I kind of disagree with
Kyle's you know framing of this
he was saying it's going to be wild at
our government building I mean are you
opposed to a bunch of [ __ ] Trump
supporters getting violent on each other
at a trump rally I mean it's kind of
like are you sad when these
anti-backsers and people who are pushing
that the coveted denial are dying from
covid really are you sad no
um I'm not
and if you don't like it then leave
um
he goes on to say we will save our
country from Doom
and make America great again I thought
you already did that
didn't they already do this make America
great again
when that thing I mean watch you make it
great
can you make it ungrate I don't know
what a schlub that looks like Gabe
Sanchez is going to be joining us here
in just a second I didn't retweet this I
thought I did look at this
I think I think Twitter is all kinds of
[ __ ] up I'm almost positive I
retweeted this earlier almost positive
hmm maybe from one of my sock accounts
ah you trolls out there go find it
go find it
see if you can find it okay um
I want to see if I can find this um
this Diamond video
of Trump's
yeah uh yep here it is
found it
why is this important you say you ask
why is this important
he does not want to do this like he does
not want to go
and do this thing
where he has to eulogize someone he
doesn't know
especially one of these clowns right
he's completely embarrassed by him
so he didn't want to eulogize him but
here's the thing
is he has to do it
he has to
how could he not how could he not just
absolutely do the fanfare
and have the opportunity to stand in
front of a bunch of sick events that are
going to yell and scream and cheer at
him
when he says the election is still in
the demands that the president please
don't prosecute me because I'm innocent
and he's guilty and Hunter Biden has a
laptop from hell like that's the thing
he's gonna say
we all know what the [ __ ] he's gonna say
the same [ __ ] over and over
but in this clip
it's funny because he doesn't appear to
even know and I think Ron points it out
here
uh yeah Ron points it up he says Trump
announces he will preside over diamond
from diamond and silk memorial service
in North Carolina this Saturday
uh they're with me from the beginning
and they never wavered
so that loyalty thing you know oh if
they would have said one crossword to
him he would say [ __ ] You [ __ ] Diamond
[ __ ] her he'd be dancing on her grave
like I am Okay let's listen to this
schlub
please join us on Saturday January 21st
in Fayetteville North Carolina she
he didn't even know the date like this
is crazy to me
they're setting up the camera
he's getting in a suit
he's getting all dolled up in Trump drag
right
with the hair and the makeup
and the stupid [ __ ] the the heels
that he wears he's probably got his his
garter belt on his core set on
with this stupid suit that's tailored to
try to make him look thin when he's not
they set up the camera they got the
background they got the lights going
and he doesn't it this this seems like
and it seems like the first take but I
almost bet this is like the 15th take of
this
this is so [ __ ] phony I mean this is
this is more phony than George Santos
let's watch I love that statement so do
I
as we celebrate the life of diamond
she lived it in a credible way there's
one you're gonna have a wonderful
celebration and ceremony
all of diamonds there's two and silk we
love silk her sisters she loved her
sister so much and they loved each other
and they really love the world
they were with me from the beginning and
they never wavered
so we're going to celebrate silk we'll
be there but I'll be there and we're
going to celebrate the life of diamond
three
see you in North Carolina thank you
listen
uh I don't know if you caught it but the
right wing was mad
that there was not a half mass for
Diamond dying from coven when she's a
Coba denier telling people not to get
the vaccine and [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here
half Mass
keep saying she is have you have you
seen this video of trump going to North
Carolina to um to eulogize Diamond I I I
I think I think he doesn't even I made a
joke about it I made a joke about it not
not today but when when he made the when
he broke the news I was like oh yeah
yeah yeah
but if we're I mean you mean are you
googly yeah you're googly yeah yeah he's
like he's he's a good you googleizer a
googolizer yeah
that's because the Gestapo the gazpacho
police are after him right yeah I mean
either either him or a guitar or robachi
you know whichever one
oh my God what a joke the guy doesn't
even know Diamond's real name
don't even know her real name you just
call her Diamond he oh he called her
down she's a diamond in the dust
oh it's so sad she's diamond dust too uh
speaking of speaking of dumb [ __ ] that
died because they're covered deniers did
you hear about this state trooper in
Washington the one that went viral for
in his he was in his um he went viral
because because he got covered well no
no he went viral with this video because
he made a a video in his in his uh
patrol car on his last day that he could
be a trooper because the Maxine mandate
went into effect the next day and he
told the governor Inslee to kiss his ass
he made this video
not viral because of like code no no he
he caught cobit okay and he he went
viral his body went viral and then he
kicked the [ __ ] bucket which oh yeah
yeah no that totally makes sense I'm so
sad I'm so sad it's such a travesty [ __ ]
him
[ __ ] him
you know [ __ ] around you find out that's
what they say right well you know again
I'm Gonna Keep dancing on these Grays
people like oh that's so nice look I'm
sorry at the end of the day you're mean
they're the ones who starving themselves
at risk they're the ones who didn't
believe science they're the ones who
didn't believe there was a public health
risk and at the end of the day if for
you know whatever reason they are the
ones that you know kicked it like
diamond
and hit the Dust
then that's on them sorry I mean isn't
their whole thing like uh
[ __ ] your feelings right I don't know
[ __ ] your feelings you know facts don't
care about your feelings uh the idea
that
um not only not only that but also
the idea that they go you have to take
responsibility I guess maybe do they say
that I don't know if they say that I
know Trump doesn't do that but I have
this idea that at one point I saw some
Republicans be like oh [ __ ] own it
take ownership of it you should totally
you should totally like take
responsibility or like I don't know I
don't know this is that you know what if
anything's just owning the lips we
[ __ ] got it dude oh man that state
trooper really owned our ass let me tell
you something
um speaking of getting owned
hell this story it just it just gets
um crazier and crazier with the Mr fraud
uh Santos but you know you know you know
the thing is the thing is though again
I've been saying like look these are not
special lies I mean Carrie Lake if
anyone remembers the Cary Lake campaign
um when it was exposed that she had a
really good friend who was a who who was
a very popular very uh in in the Arizona
area I believe in the Phoenix area yeah
very popular a very well-known drag uh
Queen man if they could friends at their
house went to the performances and you
know she was all you know we gotta we
gotta get rid of these demons and [ __ ]
and all this kind of [ __ ] anti-lgbtq
stuff when she went right wing so this
isn't like a new lie that Santos
possibly is a is a drag queen now here's
here's his statement I will say this
yeah I will say this if they had just
embraced it and said
uh uh to the drag Community right and
and and accepted the fact they're like
yeah we were part of it we accepted it
we parted we celebrated we deal the
stuff who knows maybe they would have
got a couple more votes Carrie like
wouldn't or you know she she wouldn't
have actually won right with those votes
but
at least some people might be like well
you're not a total hypocrite right well
and the other thing too is they wouldn't
drive lunatics to go to these um these
shows and threaten to kill
um you know it threatened to kill this
community right that that like to go to
these shows because it's not it's not
just it's it's not just [ __ ] I mean I
would I would trust shows a drag queen
over a good guy with a gun oh [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah a drag queen with a set of
heels
um that'll stop a bad guy with a gun
it's proven to be a fact actually it's
100 right right uh well and I mean this
is to to not know
that these are entertainment and
performances
again it just these are the same stupid
people that have no idea what the debt
ceiling is it's like it's not that
difficult to understand it's a [ __ ]
it's a show it's a show It's
Entertainment people
um but here's George Santos's uh little
statement this morning on Twitter
um for this drag queen story now I I I
gotta know from you here professionally
we're gonna look at the picture here in
a minute that you posted of how you can
tell that this is real because I know I
don't know anymore what is reality with
George Santos and what is not like it's
it is it well any Republican really but
here he's here's what here's what Mr
Santo says if that is his name which may
or may not be went by a lot of them
apparently uh I can't keep track anymore
yeah well it's the most recent Obsession
from the media claiming that I am a drag
queen or performed quote as a drag queen
is categorically false so that means
it's true yeah
um I don't know if you I'm actually
surprised I'm gonna be honest I'm
surprised he addressed this and I'm
surprised why would a dog one why Woody
why wouldn't he just shut up and trip
over a newspaper say I'm not gonna
resign yeah I mean look if if you're
gonna Dodge questions from reporters
like
this is the one thing that you decide
you know what I'm gonna [ __ ] put my
heels in yeah and not let you own this
narrative and it's like dude dude dude
dude just stop just you know what you
know what's crazy is the media this
morning they were calling him dead man
walking I'm like what are you talking
about this guy there's no criminal
charges yet there's apparently some
investigations but even criminal
indictments are not going to prevent
this guy from staying in Congress
because there is no Ethics Committee
they [ __ ] smashed it up with a hammer
for the very purpose of making sure that
George Santos is a vote for Kevin
McCarthy and the Republicans these are
scumbags these are vile lying scumbags
and he's one of them yeah he's just on
their team and he goes on to say you're
in attacking the media
as if this is the media's problem that
he has with all these lies that he's
created
um again just any old average day
Republican in that matter but he goes on
to say here in this tweet the media
continues to make outrageous claims
about my life no you did you [ __ ] yeah
and he goes on while I am working to
deliver results
what the what [ __ ] results for who
what results has as any Republican in
Congress delivered since I don't know
January 6. or the third excuse me the
third when was it when was it that he
was [ __ ] finally to speak they got
sworn in uh let's see it's okay it
wasn't so on the seventh seventh okay
right so it's not four five six seven
yeah it was that Friday he goes on no no
no no no it was the sixth because it was
the two it was the two year anniversary
oh okay yeah yeah it was January 6th
that's why it was so big right and here
here he continues to say the Tweet wraps
it up like this in a really stupid bow
um I will not be distracted nor phased
by this you're tweeting about it yeah
you you already got distracted right
here you already got distracted
okay so you want to address you won't
address your mother dying twice and then
yesterday the Washington Post came out
was like yeah so we have records and it
shows that his mom was actually in
Brazil at the time she was nowhere
that's neither NYC so that's actually
like more that's a bigger story than I
think this drag queen because I'm not
surprised that he dressed up a drag I
don't see the problem with it no not at
all I don't you dress up and drag for
your for your [ __ ] videos it's not a
big deal you're doing in this
entertainment what in the [ __ ] don't
people understand about this
and who cares if you're straight or gay
or like to dress up in a certain type of
clothes what the [ __ ] does it matter
what is it anyone else's business right
you're you're you're you're getting
crazy here but what you see here is the
idea that what did you say here what is
this what is this is this what about the
names that he's going right that's
that's his drag queen name
oh is that what they're alleging this is
yeah yeah I'm not going to say all right
here I'm going to give you this other
one yeah and this is gonna this will
allow wait no wait wait now wait a
second I want to go through this here
yeah
I can't I just sent you a side by side
that I mean oh okay so so this one's a
little better example is that what
you're saying okay you can actually see
it side by side
Santos and his Alter Ego as the drag
queen okay so this is Santos uh-huh and
this is the alter ego uh this is the
picture we were just looking at that you
posted earlier how do I know this isn't
fake
because it was shared by the drag queen
who who basically broke this story with
the reporter Eula Richard she's the drag
queen that is in uh in Brazil right but
I'm asking I'm asking because you are
you you have some Professional Knowledge
of Photoshop and yeah and trying to
figure out something no this is not
Photoshop no no no how
[Music]
how would we know that it is or it isn't
I mean you would I mean
you would be able to tell through
certain brushing up and I mean like this
is there's a level of detail here that's
decently hard you'd have to find someone
who looks just like him you'd have to
find a photo I mean here's the thing if
somebody were to photoshop it right like
he already does the he already naturally
tilts his head that way which is already
signed number one is that the um
right so if you look here he's already
got the natural tilt his cheeks and his
nose match we can't see his ears his
eyebrows go up in the same way though
they're treated in this one
um his teeth his front tooth is slightly
different and it looks like he chipped
his tooth in this version in 2008 and
and possibly got it fixed
since then and I'm not doubting this
yeah I just I just I just want to smoke
out this [ __ ] idea go back to the
other one
yeah yeah
this one here yeah yeah
so I'm just
it would be I mean look they both wear
makeup in this photo okay so uh you have
to look at this and say it'd be very
hard to look at the other one and
it'd be photos I'm not saying it's not
possible wait what you're saying
possible in both these pictures you
suspect
that George Santos who is a Maga alpha
male is wearing makeup yes 100
thing that is incredibly alpha male
I mean I wear makeup all the time right
I go on stage I go on to set yeah I do
this I do this maybe maybe when I'm
making a video I didn't get sleep so I
got a little dark circles on my ass I
put a little makeup so it's not
distracting it's all part of the [ __ ]
show man let's take a look let's take a
look here we gotta get your makeup
artists really dark I got a little so so
later if I make a video I might pull
something on you know oh okay so you
might you might you might you know the
other thing you may make it [ __ ]
crazy you know when you're doing the um
the Donald Trump Jr beard you then I
don't wear makeup I don't this is this
is all natural this is Natty baby yeah
this is Natty this is nanny so what I do
when I do Don Jr yeah I mean I have worn
makeup I have more makeup because I've
been in plays and I've done performances
so I had to wear makeup and it didn't
you're on stage you wear lipstick
because the thing is the way that the
lights work in order for people to see
your lips so it doesn't just look like a
[ __ ] say same color face because the
lights are so bright for people in the
back and then drowning out lipstick well
you know the other thing too is stage
makeup for like stage lights it looks
really weird when you're not under the
stage lights because they're true yeah
they're trying to hide the Shadows close
up you're like wow that's a lot that
really that is a lot going on when you
look from afar you're like oh that
person looks totally normal
and I think there was a local story here
recently uh somewhere around here or
maybe it was uh I don't know on Twitter
where uh parents got into a fist fight
um over stage makeup at a high school
play because like okay well because
because they saw the stage makeup and
they're like that looks like [ __ ] and
they didn't understand that because of
the direction of the lights and [ __ ] the
reason why they're putting the makeup on
is to make sure that the audience can
see their face yeah yeah right yeah
again it's also yeah it's just like one
of those things yeah it's insane you
know like you know people putting on
darker makeup you know obviously because
the lights are so bright and things like
that and you know you're wearing you
might be mascara you know lipstick blush
just like here yeah just like here right
it's all what is what's wrong with
what's wrong with this though what's
wrong with this I don't know
nothing wrong with Santos Santos I I
gotta I gotta is upset is upset because
it goes against his far right ID
theology now right that he adopted for
the Republicans and look if I would I
would laugh my ass off
if this was the one thing
that was like uh Republicans like nah
[ __ ] this is like Bridgeview like they
were okay with the Holocaust lies they
were okay with the Shady money [ __ ] it
they were of course they why wouldn't
they be okay with those they were okay
with stealing money from a veteran or in
a sick dog GoFundMe let me tell you
something there was a guy in 2016 that
ran for president he bragged About
gramming Women by the [ __ ] he literally
said I grabbed by and there's they love
it there's nothing you know yeah no no I
know they do
I don't know if you know this guy but
also his son ran a charity where they
stole money from children and then his
wife yeah his wife's son or his son's
wife yeah uh I don't know about Baron
but yeah his his son's wife Lara Trump
stole money from a dog charity yeah
right the whole family the whole family
I mean Charities man there's this same
guy the same guy has some shitty Motel
down in South Florida and he invites the
the the losing Republican candidate of
the Arizona uh race yeah
residency down there now and she she
[ __ ] she loved drag queens before she
hated him yeah I don't understand what
the problem with this she loved him
until the point it became this whole
fake outrage drag queen
they were like oh they're doing Story
Time God forbid you'll educate them guys
we God forbid we we give these children
well they don't want kids to read Dave
Sanchez if they but not only they can
read then they can learn if they can
learn then they'll know the truth
knowledge is power but it's not only
it's not only oh why is this drag queen
reading to our kids it's the fact that
one they're threatened by someone that a
large majority of people are like yeah
man this person's great it's cool
they're very accepting they're very
welcoming they understand that they're
part of a marginalized community that
that receive hate and receive uh insane
vile gross disgusting comments and
they're strong and they've got courage
and they're Brave to do what they do and
stand up and go on stage and perform and
and provide entertainment because that's
what it is entertainment for Their
audience for their a lot of them are
really [ __ ] good at it a lot of them
are really [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] easy
yeah I don't know if you've seen uh some
of these some of these uh uh drag queens
dance but holy [ __ ] like the shoes
they're wearing dancing I mean I'm a
halfway decent dancer but I couldn't
dance in those shoes no [ __ ] way I'd
be nice for my ankles there's a hole
kill my whole thing and what I'll say is
yeah there's there's
undoubtedly so much talent but speaking
of talent the person the the drag queen
who revealed you know articles newspaper
photos all of the stuff you're like yeah
this is George Santos or Anthony or
devolder now this is this is the drag
queen in Brazil right right this is the
drag queen in Brazil and then she uh
they they said uh what was the quote it
was hold on hold on it was um basically
George Santos didn't do it
professionally and he never had the
glamor for it like so he wasn't so so he
wasn't the best at the performance part
probably he wasn't yeah he wasn't good I
mean
I gotta tell you Gabe Sanchez I gotta
tell you something
George Santos here doesn't make a bad
looking it doesn't make a bad looking
woman when you when you make put makeup
on him he's he's a he's a he's a halfway
decent looking Dragon I mean she's
beautiful this this is not a bad picture
this is not someone who you would think
was not attractive right I mean poor guy
you know he looks really unattractive I
don't know I don't know who he is or or
I I honestly the joke I made this
morning about this because I was like
you got a mock-up you got a model yeah
yeah
we don't you know fickle is Einhorn
Einhorn
because that's a that's exactly what
this is Right Here Right you've got this
guy who you know
has another Persona or at least did have
another persona
and it was like oh my God you know
einhorn's a man you know like oh my God
your gun is digging into my hip right
it's
it's such a that's such a great when
he's burning but it's like he's got the
plunger you know oh my God like I said I
don't think it would be a lot of votes
but you could find yourself maybe maybe
stepping over and and creating a bridge
between one community and another but
instead Republicans want to villainize
these people for something they do
I definitely don't want to villainize
um George Santos because again he makes
I think he makes a good looking drag
queen he's right over here you don't
have to use this to villainize George
Santos George Santos already made
himself the villain well he was like he
was like look
I'm gonna make myself the [ __ ]
villain of My Own Story right the fact
that he won't just own this right the
fact that he just won't own this is the
is the shitty part and he's he's he's
categorically false
oh my God I mean yeah but this morning
it was not only this but he was also
talking about how many dogs he reduced
oh yeah is that is did he put that on
his [ __ ] Twitter too yeah that sounds
okay let me see if I can find it yeah
for those who don't know George Santos
decided today was going to be the day in
which he fought the fake news
uh uh and the fake news being true real
news he said I didn't I didn't take
money from this dog GoFundMe that'd be
terrible here it is here's the audience
is this the one you're talking about
yeah this is the one the reports here's
what here's what uh George Santos if
that's oh no no this is the updated one
because it got called out for the last
one so go back to his account
did he did he edit it or did he no no he
made a new one
I don't see the one that let me see if
yeah she didn't find it yeah yeah I'll
read the updated one here and then yeah
we'll get the original
um he says he apparently he resets or re
redoes the Tweet here the statement ah
he deleted it but I can find it [ __ ]
okay so yeah of course so um uh George
we the internet's forever [ __ ] yep I
don't know if you know that Sam so you
quote treat and you have the URL and
then you think you think George Santos
would know that the internet's forever
he did he did help it this is why you
screenshot and this morning I was like
nah I'm just gonna quote tweet
see I got you on the quote tweet thing
yeah yeah because you want to talk to
him directly sometimes like sometimes
I gotta find someone's screenshot now
anyway okay so yeah George Santos if
that is his name
um tweets this about the dog charity
story where he stole three thousand
dollars from a veteran not trying to
raise money for his dog who had some
sort of uh I think it was cancer right
and the dog ended up dying that's the
story that is being reported
um
he says the reports that I would let a
dog die is shocking and insane it really
isn't uh my work my work in animal
advocacy
was the labor of love and hard work um
make me want to puke
hard work he changed his name to get
more money and as soon as he hit the
ball yeah
look every every anti-semitic person
knows that if you change your name to
seem Jewish that more Jewish people will
give you more money every anti-semitic
person knows that Gabe Sanchez
um he says over the past 24 hour which
is kind of weird how he did that I have
I have remember he's from Brazil I think
or it's Russia who knows
really I I thought he was I thought he
was a victim of the Holocaust
he was he was uh never mind okay well
we'll keep going here it's hard to keep
track of this [ __ ]
um he says uh I received pictures of
dogs I helped rescue throughout the
years along with supportive messages uh
prove it yeah and that's what I say
these distractions won't stop me stop
you from what running from the reporters
in the hallway like that's the only
thing he's doing right now is going from
the elevator to his office from his
office to the elevator like that's
literally he's got I mean look he he
gets in a fair amount of steps but I'm
sure that his uh and he's going at a
pretty good stride I mean he's [ __ ]
his counter is counting those steps yeah
I mean like you know yeah baby yeah but
he goes from he go he walks in he walks
in and they don't have to walk through
any metal detectors anymore all right
thanks Lauren bobert uh walks in goes to
the elevator up the elevator to his
office from his office to the elevator
down to the house floor back because
they can't proxy vote anymore remember
so he's got to be there on on the actual
floor so they so so they basically made
it to where George Santos can't hide in
his office and vote by proxy
[ __ ] got to get out in the open
exactly out in the wild as it were that
way they can hunt him down these
journalists to ask him these simple
questions now this clip is uh is this of
the veteran this is all the money yeah
and uh and one of the people that work
at the um the non-profit okay so which
one is which do you know the game with
the really the guy the guy in the left
the guy with the beard is the veteran
okay okay and then the other guy is the
one who's worked which with Santos or
whatever no he he works at uh I I don't
know if it was the non-profit before but
he works as a non-profit that okay okay
well well uh let's check this out this
is uh from CNN this is the veteran who
is making claims that George Santos
definitely stole three thousand dollars
uh and kill this dog what would you say
to him if you
if he was here now what would you say to
him
do you have a heart
do you have a soul no
he doesn't
he's a republican what
he probably would lie about that
oh God damn I mean I I don't want you to
ever hurt anybody like you hurt me again
George
and nobody else should ever have to go
through that I almost killed myself when
that dog died
that's why I'm here I don't want him to
be able to do this again
what do you want to happen
you know one thing about working in the
charity is thank God we have people that
care okay so the gang talking now his
name is Michael bull he's the president
of the New Jersey Veterans Network so it
is a it is a veterans charity that this
guy uh is a part of it and if you look
to the if you look to the right of the
veteran that box right there is
the ashes of the dog
are you serious yeah oh [ __ ]
damn okay let's watch
um we expect nothing to come out of this
from Santos but I know that America
has people here that love veterans and
they've already reached out to us and
offered to help so I'm happy to know
that there's people out there that
really see the good that we do and
really want to show love to our veterans
and help them so I see the good out of
this Santos really took a okay so that's
the the box that you're saying the wood
box there is what happened because
remember you know the veteran was like
hey my dog is sick and George Santos or
Anthony zabrovski or whatever the [ __ ]
he goes by said yeah I'll help you raise
the money and this was this was a
service dog right it was a service dog
and because he's a veteran and so you
know um
he has a service and he has a service
animal helps him and all the things I
mean there's a there's a bond I mean you
know if you have a dog I have dogs like
people when you whether it's cats or
whatever it is there there is that like
unconditional love there is that
attachment in that bond that you have
okay and that's just for a pet now when
you have a service animal a a dog that's
actually
helping you whether it's coping you know
emotional kind of stability uh actual
services to help get medicine or open
the door whatever it might be like
there's another Bond beyond that where
it's a dependency and you become you
know
lifelong Partners right in that sense of
like you are now in this together
and the fact that George Sanchez was
like I'll help you raise the money
and then raise the three thousand
dollars and then just ghosted and then
[ __ ] ghosted so now this veteran has
no no way of of getting the services
needed to help this dog and the dog
passes away basically he just Steals and
fraudulently steals this guy's story to
raise three like there's there's people
who are like ah man it's like stealing
baby from a can or like stealing candy
from a baby this is like you know this
is [ __ ] way worse way [ __ ] worse
so let me ask you on this because has
has GoFundMe said anything about this
have they put out a statement on this I
don't know about the 3 000 because I
mean they would have record of this if
that's the case right
um now in the in the background you see
the picture of um of the dog there and
the veteran and looks like in his pickup
truck
um well let's let's finish this clip up
while you're seeing if you can see if uh
GoFundMe has made any statements piece
of my heart when he did this I I
my opinion of humanity was very very
extremely diminished crashed into the
floor and the outpouring I've seen over
the last two days from people commenting
on my story online especially on
Facebook and uh um YouTube
everybody that is positive about this
I've seen not seen a single troll
um people want to give me money they
want to give me another service dog they
want to help me with dog food and stuff
like that and they've really brought me
back up with my value and my my insight
in humanity again uh George wrecked that
these people with their hearts and what
they're they've been offering to me
I trust people again we're able to pay
the bills and all of that I had to
Panhandle to have the dog euthanized and
uh cremated
God damn
um that's not not only are you like oh
[ __ ] this
I depend so much on this animal right
right because because really it's not
about the money almost like this guy is
like you stole three thousand dollars
for me he's like you stole my soul you
bastard you stole my [ __ ] you stole
my outlook on life you stole my my my
confidence in humanity that's what he's
saying he's not saying you stole three
thousand dollars from me the guys
there's this stuff about the money yeah
there's so if anyone hasn't seen it
there's a there's a little like
docu-series on Netflix called uh I just
want to get the the name right it looks
like it looks like um
um Nassau County
uh officials are helping to fundraise
three thousand dollars and other people
are you know working to possibly get
another service animal like you said
um but you have to be a special kind of
evil
if I can do that to someone
steal their money leave them helpless
and then when they're when they're
service animal their companion their
best friend their family member
passes away right you gotta pay to
euthanize and get the cremate uh get the
dog cremated
and they have to and he has to paint
like so it's like [ __ ] salt in a
wound man right and so if anyone hasn't
seen it there's a docu-series called
don't [ __ ] with cats hunting an internet
killer right okay there's like the and I
highly recommend it it's a really [ __ ]
up story about what happened but it
shows you that there's like one rule on
the internet okay you don't [ __ ] with
cats and I'd say the other rule is you
don't [ __ ] with dogs right these are
animals that are only there they [ __ ]
they're dude my dogs could tell you the
top three things they love is [ __ ]
eating snuggling and like chasing the
ball [ __ ] life is super simple easy
going
I envy them for the things that they
have to worry about okay
dude that was their day in a nutshell
okay the same thing goes with cats or
other pets that you have they're there I
mean depending on you but they're there
giving you that same type of emotional
like Comfort like people during the
pandemic super helpful like these are
all things but
the fact that somebody like George
Santos is so easily able to fundraise
for someone and then steal that [ __ ]
money and then leave that guy helpless
on the street to Panhandle for the money
to pay to euthanize and pay to create
cremate his dog is [ __ ] insane
and so anyway I recommend if anyone
hasn't seen it watch the little
docu-series don't [ __ ] with cats uh it's
really good but it shows you
that there are certain rules in life
okay there are certain there are certain
lines you don't cross and [ __ ] with
someone's cat [ __ ] with someone's
sick dog and stealing their money it's
not just and here's the thing it's not
just George Santos being like hey I will
help you fundraise for this money to
help get this surgery and then leaves
right that would be something if he just
like ghosted and didn't commit to it
totally different than the guy being
like hey I'm gonna fundraise for you
meets the goal and then takes the money
and then dips out
it's just it's just [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] nasty man like the people that
are out and that and and again George
Santos is a 100
verifiable lying Psychopathic Republican
who's also a drag queen too
but look
that's the Republican party they hate
themselves they hate veterans they hate
[ __ ] dogs they're [ __ ] terrible
people you know when they care about
anyone in a clip with the veteran where
he's telling the story about how this uh
this story's been exposed and uh Santa's
has been shown to be a fraud because he
really stole his story more than he yeah
because Santos didn't give a [ __ ] about
him or his dog he just wanted his story
so he could raise 3 000 bucks and take
the money yeah um and apparently
GoFundMe uh has suspended his ability to
fundraise Santos that is right
um I mean under what name really yeah
but here's but here's the thing here's
the thing is that
out of all those people that showed
support right and the veterans was
talking about people want to send money
dog food get him a new service dog just
just saying hey man everything's gonna
be all right we're here for you right we
support you right all the all the great
messages how many of those gave sanjas
how many of those do you think are
self-identified Republicans let's send
him those messages
then send him those messages oh none
yeah right I mean that's where we're at
that's where we're at I mean I I would
imagine the fact that Nassau County
because remember Nassau County already
came out and they're like this guy is
should not be running so the fact that
there are some Republicans you know so
there's so look I'll say this it's not
all Republicans there are some
Republicans who definitely are like oh
man that's really [ __ ] up and I'm so
sorry about that the fact that
uh
Nassau County who's already gone against
and out and outwardly spoken against
George Santos
um the fact
that they are helping to fundraise and
again three thousand dollars in the
grand scheme is a lot of money
considering how much money is fundraised
in politics really who gives a [ __ ]
about three thousand dollars it had a
service dog right I mean no amount of
money is going to bring back the guy's
dog yeah I mean it might get him an
another dog but it's not gonna bring
back his dog I mean and the thing and
the thing that that stings the most
because that's not like oh this dog had
a cancer or a tumor and it was like oh
we're past the stage you really got to
put this dog down it was you can save
this dog's life what was that what was
the condition what was the condition do
we know it was uh
uh hold on
um let me find it okay
but I mean I I wouldn't imagine there's
too many people who self-identify as
Republicans who who swoop in and made
sure to help this guy and give him
support just even just encouraging
messages because he said there was no
trolls you know what he meant by that
there was no people who support
frauds like I don't know Trump the OG
Santos and then George Santos yeah
um here's the thing
is that if we if we expect anything
um more out of these people than what
we're expecting at dear Santos we're
we're barking up the wrong tree again
yeah he's not an outlier here I'm sure
that there are plenty of stories from
what you mentioned earlier the Laura
Trump where she was stealing [ __ ]
money from a dog charity right she was
two million dollars
yeah she was rerouting the funds from
the from the charity to Trump and it was
a it was a life-threatening surgery but
it was a stomach tumor that the dog had
oh I see so they they go again like the
tumor and yeah yeah and so the
had had the dog gotten the surgery that
cost three thousand dollars but
unfortunately and here's the other thing
too
like if if he probably like he
panhandled to pay and I don't know how
much the cost of euthanizing and
cremating the dog was but
I almost feel like he because because I
think the thing that is really [ __ ] up
about this is George Santos being like
yeah we're fundraising for you right and
I don't know how long the the goal took
to accomplish right but that whole time
that whole [ __ ] time that veteran is
waiting right right
and he's like oh man we're hitting the
goals the dog's gonna live right and
that whole time again I don't know how
long it took to achieve that goal but
during that whole time he's waiting
depending on George Santos because he's
expecting they're gonna fulfill the goal
because it's getting there right but
during that time he could have if he
would have known that George Santos was
gonna [ __ ] him over and do that to him
he probably could have raised the money
on his own or gone through another
organization or gotten some sort of
other uh Aid to help pay for the surgery
but George Santos [ __ ] strung him
along made him believe that he was going
to help pay for the surgery as the money
was coming in and then goes I'm out like
[ __ ] disgusting well
I now now I know why Santos tweeted what
he tweeted this morning about this
I figured it out just seeing the story
seeing the interviews
um watching this develop in the last I
don't know we've been talking about it
for about 15-20 minutes the reason why
is because George Santos needs the
trolls George Santos needs the the help
from all the vile disgusting gross
people out there that support Trump
support Maga support Kevin McCarthy
support the Maga terrorists the economic
terrorist in our house he needs the
support of them so if he does this thing
where he says ah [ __ ] that that's not
true that's all [ __ ] then they'll
come to his defense because they're not
coming to his defense right now so he's
got to put out a statement so I I
actually
um am believing right now that that's
the reason why he did both statements on
the drag queen story and the dog story
because those are the two stories
those are the two stories that are gonna
smash him up the most yeah but to think
that he's a dead man walking here I in
Congress and I don't think this is going
to hurt his reputation with Republicans
I really don't I think the right-wing
trolls are going to defend this idiot
now that he's put out statements that
he's vehemently denying what we can see
in front of our eyes what do you think I
think that's a pretty good theory I
think that's I think I think it is a
good theory in terms of trying to uh
develop some sort of uh uh Army to right
I mean because to develop a narrative
against it because yeah he doesn't have
it and I'm surprised that it took him
you know I don't know was it two days I
guess two days for him to kind of come
back and be like they're telling me
about they're talking about lies
yesterday yesterday might have been the
thing that broke the camel's back right
yesterday's story is the thing that
every Republican in that party is so
adamantly [ __ ] like so against and
having any Drag Queen near them uh
cooties and near their children right
because they're going to indoctrinate
them into the wokism politics of
America's gen Z [ __ ] leftists all
that [ __ ] right
but I do all the good but all the good
stuff all the good you know God forbid
we have free health care and free
education and things oh you Marxist
socialist mommy yeah you're gonna
destroy our country but I I do I do
think there's Merit in the idea that
he's trying to
um
rally trolls by saying it's fake news
and I've and the other thing too is it's
not just it's not just hey this is a lie
don't believe it right what he's doing
is he's saying hey this is a lie don't
believe it
they're trying to distract and stop me
from helping you look at what I've done
I mean again they've done nothing every
bill that they've passed in the house
because of the Republican majority which
by again is by a four-person narrow
majority
has been done for just
performative kind of action right it's
all performative because none of that
[ __ ] is going to pass in the Senate and
none of that [ __ ] would ever pass the
desk of Joe Biden and he would never
sign it so everything they do is
performative because they say as Kev
McCarthy as long as they're talking to
write that [ __ ] speech he said we're
gonna do this we're going to do that
we're going to do this we're going to do
that and yeah sure they fulfill the
promise of doing that in the house but
they'll never actually make it a real
thing outside of that are you claiming
that all the Republicans are just as big
of a fraud as George Santos is that what
you're playing here because they're not
there to govern man they're just there
to show up and just become famous and
get their money and act like they're
doing their job and just act like
they're actually representative and act
like they're actually governing and and
and working to to actually help and and
represent their constituents and the
people that voted them in
but that's all they are they're just
actors so I guess it makes sense that
George Santos you know wears makeup and
does drag and all stuff I wouldn't be
surprised if there are other Republicans
who also maybe have done that in the
past or do that now in secrecy you know
[ __ ] there's nothing wrong with it but
you can't call it out and say it's evil
and then at the same time be someone who
did that or does that right
yeah
you can do that if you are a republican
speaking of people who's who get in Drag
and get pictures confused I don't mean
to jump stories here but we're going
down
apparently last year in a deposition in
this Eugene Carroll case where Trump she
claims
um that he raped her okay and it's a
it's it's a civil case this isn't a
criminal case yeah yeah and he's suing
uh she's suing him because basic two
cases right right but this defamation
case is because he basically is taking
the tenement that I wouldn't rape her
because she's not my type that's the
whole basis of the defamation right now
in this deposition which the um Haba you
remember Haba you remember oh yeah
[ __ ] bone end the reason why we have
these depositions is because she's
basically
um just said yeah go ahead and release
them right I mean I think that's pretty
much well she got I think it was it was
last week Friday or whatever it was she
got or Saturday I'm trying to measure it
but she got
some of them released right right and
then the more of them will be coming out
uh today this week I forget when well
I'm no bin myself I'm not a lawyer so
right right but I'm just saying the
legality of it is
also so yeah there's also a bigger legal
aspect too because so there's one case
for people who don't know there's two
there's two cases that are against Trump
one was filed while he was President of
the United States so there's a whole
like what's constitutional and and what
is protected as a president can you sue
kind of thing that is still being
litigated right now then you got this
other one this rape defamation case
where we see these uh these transcripts
come out
and that one was done because New York
passed the um the sexual abuse I forget
the actual title but the sexual abuse or
assault Survivor right and so they can
go back to a certain period of time and
so she was able to go back uh you know
statute and go back and actually file a
lawsuit against Trump as a private
citizen so now we've got private citizen
lawsuit and we've got presidential
lawsuit okay and the presidential
lawsuit remember if anyone if anyone uh
can remember this this is where Bill
Barr came in and was like the justice
department is going to protect and
represent Trump and eventually that was
some [ __ ] thing that actually got
dropped so now there's two lawsuits now
the reason the presidential one is so
important and I haven't seen a lot of
people talk about this but maybe they
have and maybe Ben has but I haven't
seen one is the fact that this is so
important is because it opens the
[ __ ] door to other lawsuits like uh
like Ruby Bridges right and Ruby Freeman
and and and um and the Georgia uh the
Georgia defamation you know that came
from that right and he's still attacking
her and her you know and of course he is
why wouldn't untrue social so like is
like truth social posts have been
brought up in this deposition transcript
that we've read from last week so we
know that this is real [ __ ] that he's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] stepping into the
[ __ ] and then smearing and into the
[ __ ] crevices of the shoe throwing
the ketchup on the wall which will show
you that Jack Smith is just just letting
just letting the feed of Truth social
pop up on on Trump's account right and
just like up screenshot screenshot
screenshot I bet Jack Smith can't wait
for this guy to get back on yeah he
can't wait for him to get back yeah now
here here's another picture side by side
here okay uh it looks like it's still
them at the time like at the same age at
the time I don't know we're just gonna
look at these pictures yeah okay
um Margie says here the adult survivors
Act is what the news that's what it is
yeah I didn't know the name so I didn't
thank you paraphrase it but thank you
best moderators in the world you're
helping us helping us find facts as we
go
um
so in this deposition in this transcript
that was released I think it was this
morning or late last night which wasn't
anyways it doesn't matter
um it's revealed that Donald Trump was
shown photos
of Eugene Carroll and he said yeah
that's my wife that's that's Marla
um now in this now I don't know I I
don't know e Gene Carroll personally and
I don't know Marla Maples personally I
don't know them personally
I've seen a lot of pictures of them
um especially Eugene Carroll and all all
ages right so like they're aging Carol's
lifespan I've seen different I've seen
her on video
um giving interviews about this
if someone presented this picture to me
and said which one is Aging Care on
which one is Marla Maples I would be
able to do it right and I don't know him
personally I wasn't married to one of
them and I didn't have an encounter with
one of them where they're alleging it's
rape right
um but he did he was married to Marla
Maples I don't know if any if the
Christians out there that hate watching
Christians know this I know you know
this but let me drop you some facts here
Marla Maples is the woman
that he married the second time this is
his second ex-wife okay and he married
her because he was cheating on his first
wife which is now his first ex-wife
she's the one where all the documents
are in her casket apparently allegedly
maybe I don't know who who if I recall
didn't she she wrote a
she wrote a book and I couldn't think
Trump raped her yeah okay okay I just
want to make sure that I have that right
yeah
um but I could tell the difference
between Marla Maples and Eugene Carroll
and this couldn't you
yeah it's pretty pretty I mean even in
the black and white photo that they said
was in the court dock because what
happens here is so the they're going
through the Q a or they're going through
the questions do we know what picture it
was do we know what picture yeah yeah
yeah yeah can you find that picture for
me for sure yeah
is it the one with the dog in it
uh no okay it's uh because there's one
going around the internet a black and
white photo with the dog in it there's a
black and white photo of them at a party
or some sort of event kind of
get-together but Trump but Trump
mistakenly and confuses e Gene Carroll
for his ex-wife Marla Maples yeah and
when he does this in the transcript if
you go read the transcript which you can
you can find a screenshot of it
but he he claims it's Marla he's like
yeah that's my wife and Haba the the
[ __ ] bonehead the one with all the
shitty legal things she she has to
correct him because she even knows yeah
she even knows looking at the photo that
that's not Marla Mabel that that that's
that's because in the in it so I just
sent you the I said I just sent you the
photo so to kind of do a little
background narration here what happens
is this is the actual transcript that it
goes right this is the play-by-play they
say answer at some point during the
process I saw it I guess it's that
that's her husband John Johnson who was
an anchor at for NBC 19 Harold's husband
at the time right right okay I mean I
didn't I don't know him but I thought he
was pretty good at what he did I don't
even know the woman woman being aging
Carol okay
now we already know that even in his own
statement from last week and the
transcripts that came out from the
deposition that he
he was uh
um
saying the complete opposite right he
said I don't even know the woman she's
crazy but then he knew exactly who she
was okay
he goes in this he said I don't even
know the woman I don't know who it's
Marla right you're saying so question
from the uh Eugene Carroll's Council
you're saying Marla is in this photo
Trump that's Marla yeah that's my wife
my wife
question
which woman are you pointing to then
have a jumps in and goes no that's Carol
and the witness uh Trump I believe it
goes oh I see
then uh the attorney goes the person you
pointed to was EG and Carol Haba says
that's your wife
then the attorney goes and the person
the woman on your right was and then
Trump goes I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson
Haba says that's Carol Trump goes that's
Carol
it's it's just Bad News Bears man the
guy doesn't know their their entire
defense of he she's not my type totally
[ __ ] falls apart in that moment right
just totally crazy I mean and here's
it's not surprising right it's not
surprising because Trump is is so so
narrow-minded right he sees a beautiful
woman he shows some money that he has on
him probably [ __ ] fake money says hey
come and hang out my Rolls Royce or come
do this or whatever I've got these
buildings I've got my name on a thing
turns out obviously he's a big [ __ ]
fraud and a cheat and he's a he's a
terrible human
but he marries one woman you don't say
you don't he cheats he cheats and then
marries another woman right he cheats on
her marries another woman he cheats on
his current wife okay his current wife
Melania who who the closets he can't get
into okay
he cheats on her with Stormy Daniels and
pays her a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars for what she says was the worst
60 seconds of her life
that is Trump that is Trump he's he's a
massage
I don't want to defend Milani here but
would you let the guy in your closet no
hell no I wouldn't let him anywhere near
my closet hell no I wouldn't even near
him like considering that Baron is her
child I wouldn't let Trump near his own
kid because if you look if you look is
he is he allowed to go near him I don't
know I don't know I don't know I mean
there wasn't even would he even know
Baron if he was shown a picture would he
be like no that's that's I don't know
Baron is taller than Trump so who knows
maybe maybe Trump isn't the actual
father I don't know but I do know after
they left the White House Melania and
baron went to New York Trump went to
Florida they went to New York and Milani
was like I want to give this kid as much
of a normal life outside of this world
as I can I wouldn't you know I don't I
don't hold it against her to try to do
that for their kid right your kid in the
spotlight as the president's kid a lot
of pressure a lot of stress a lot of
Paparazzi a lot of people taking photos
a lot of people sharing stories that
aren't true all this crazy [ __ ]
so the idea that
Melania wouldn't want him in the closet
totally makes sense totally [ __ ] adds
up to this whole story that they live in
separate bedrooms
down the hall [ __ ] separate bedrooms
separate closets in the house
on the other [ __ ] side of the resort
right okay she's like why I can't say
I'll live at the first hole you can live
at the 18th right like yes I'm not
trying to defend or anything but
wouldn't if you had to live in the same
building wouldn't you live on the
opposite end of that [ __ ] yeah
totally yeah it's 100 so but I just want
to clarify for the audience this is the
actual photo that he was pointing at
when he was pointing at e Gene Carroll
saying that it is Marla that's my wife
yeah when he was spawning at uh Eugene
Carroll and um if you're not sure who e
Gene Carroll is in this photo
um
I don't know what to tell you
maybe you know in in the in the the
thing too is like because you've got to
remember like so for people who don't
know Trump raped agent Carroll in a
department store okay right
and maybe in this moment he was like oh
yeah that's the that's my wife and
because maybe he just feels like that's
what he does with all women like it's
all [ __ ] he's not you know he's not
quote-unquote raping them in his mind
he's having sex with him right and they
like that they like that because he said
that in the last opposition he made this
assertion and claimed that EG and Carol
likes that type of stuff she likes being
raped or she likes being raped she liked
being sexually assaulted which is
[ __ ] disgusting and gross what what
that is
but doesn't that even just give
indication that if he knows that about
her that he did it oh yeah yeah yeah 100
he knows who she is he knows absolutely
100
undeniably who she is she wanted it kind
of thing is what yes I mean that's what
he said right he was like she liked
sexual assault but I didn't [ __ ] rape
her that's what he said he's like she
liked it rough but I didn't do that
it's really it's really [ __ ]
confusing I already know that if if he
didn't do it and he's like I don't know
who she is she's great like and that's
the other thing too in the deposition
from last week he was like I don't know
who she is she's a nobody but she's sick
she's crazy like he knows enough about
her to talk [ __ ] about it to claim he
doesn't know about her okay so let's
back up here with the with the
what he knows about how she likes it
right right
um
I'm not not gonna I'm not King shaming
anybody some people like it ref I'm sure
some people like it way rougher than
others
some people like to be very intimate I'm
sure in their lovemaking which you know
it's your privacy in your bedroom as
long as it's consensual you know fine
great whatever
thing is is how in the [ __ ] would he
know what she likes and what she doesn't
like or what she would do or not do in
the case of what someone would do to her
if he didn't do it right
if you don't know her how would you know
she likes that right
right
how would you how would you what are you
trying to cover up here dude right
and how and he obviously remembers it
because if he remembers the the detail
that she likes what I wasn't doing yeah
supposedly allegedly she's accusing me
of this but I definitely didn't do that
even though she liked it if I did do it
right but I didn't because I don't like
it she liked it and then goes on to
truth social and he's like this lady so
crazy I don't know who she is meanwhile
I'm sure Trump is like
he has that moment like memorialized in
his brain right he has all of these
moments where he does these things
against women right where yes
Cindy says for Facebook he's actually
confessing this is him all the time we
did this yesterday we did this yesterday
with the stupid empty classified
documents with other folks I'm telling
you after the post that I've seen on
true social yesterday about the empty
classified folders and their keepsakes I
am almost guaranteeing you that Jack
Smith is going to prosecute Donald Trump
for whatever the hell was supposed to be
in those folders I'm almost guaranteeing
at this point how could you not how
could you not he does this every time
remember all the all the projection that
they have is really just a confession
that they that they're making right and
Trump 100 is the gives a master class on
it because
he just [ __ ] admits to all these
things right I just took the folders
guys I gave him back the classified
papers again like we said yesterday
there was no way you would be in a
[ __ ] skiff okay with people who are
of military rank or Personnel from
different intelligence agencies which
again he bashed and totally [ __ ] on
but oh yeah that was uh
listen I watched this um this bit from
Leslie Jones yeah she's doing great I
want to play it here but the the
copyright thing won't allow us yeah
um
Bean does from YouTube's here says
Leslie Jones on Boston's MLK statue she
talked about have you ever been ate out
yeah and she says betcha Tony knows how
to go down on a woman I can neither
confirm nor deny
rather I would or wouldn't and did last
night anyways let's move on let's move
on let's move on to some uh more
business here because I know I know this
aging Carol story is going to develop
more and more and more as well
I don't know I don't know if this is all
of the rest of the deposition transcript
or if there are more that are going to
trickle out right
um either way it doesn't look good for
Trump Trump's going to be more pissed I
don't know what he's saying on Truth
social today but he's going to continue
to admit more crimes and more criming
and it's just not gonna it's not gonna
go good for him man like the guy again
they use truth social [ __ ] posts in
this stuff in this [ __ ] deposition as
evidence of things he said against him
and also uh Joe Biden so uh
you better expect that Jack Smith and
everyone else who's going against him is
going to use they're like oh hey we
don't actually need to do any more
background research we just need to have
a live feed of Trump's truth Social
account and just watch what he says just
watch what he says he's just messing
he's just screaming screenshot just get
it in confession he doesn't delete his
posts so that's [ __ ] bananas yeah you
would think that somebody would be like
hey you might want to take that down huh
yeah they live forever okay so the next
story that I want to move to and I don't
have a really good transition for this
one other than other than
um you know domestic terrorists love
domestic Terrors so let's talk about the
Pena thing is there any updates I know
there might be a few updates in this New
Mexico case than what we talked about
yesterday right
um obviously this guy was arraigned um
after we were on air I believe yeah so I
watched I think I think I have a picture
but go ahead yeah yeah so I uh I watched
here let me see if I can find it uh uh
hold on
um I had to look up yesterday
oh
[Music]
here's a picture of him being uh
arraigned uh yeah so he showed up and
basically uh they he didn't he didn't um
you know say guilty not guilty kind of
thing you know whatever he was admitted
to
what they did was they're holding him
the judge is like yeah you're gonna
you're gonna have another court date
it's gonna be February 1st is when he's
coming back so he'll be back in a few
weeks or two weeks right
um
but they're holding him without bail or
without cash bail
so he's gonna sit in the in the jail
till February 1st
and
I I say it I say it in my what was that
that'll probably be coming out tomorrow
it'll definitely be coming out tomorrow
um
that right now this is just the initial
charges they've given them okay right
they just arraigned him on the charger
yeah and he just like announced it to
him officially and put it on court
record that hey yeah you understand
you're being charged with this right so
there's 15 charges that range from
firing of uh shooting a firearm or
having a firearm out you know shooting
from the motor moving or you know uh
stationary motor vehicle shooting at a
dwelling the other thing too is
so Pena actually showed up at the last
shooting that was a representative state
representative Linda Lopez's home right
that was the one where the Bulls went
into the child's the daughter's room
but the way that conspiracy law works is
that he never even had to be there on
the scene to shoot the bullets right so
he's got four counts of conspiracy
because he was the one behind the scenes
telling them and hiring them to well
yeah because he paid 500 bucks to four
Dudes right exactly now
um I want I want to tell people the
reason why these are all state charges
and not federal charges is because
there's no federal charge for domestic
terrorism right um there is there is a
federal charge and I don't know if
they'll try to connect the two but there
is so keep in mind that so he's a he's a
felon and he's not supposed to have a
firearm and he had a firearm and he used
it for something that was very very bad
right
um
it's very unlikely gave Sanchez that a
federal judge will will buy that charge
and the reason why is because his
felonies aren't Federal their state
right however however what so first off
Jose Trujillo the guy whose car Pena's
car that he was in that had the 800
fentanyl lace pills this is how they
caught him they pulled him up AR-15 in
the Glock in the card that was used at
these shootings he's been obviously uh
investigated or uh charged with federal
charges okay so he's got federal charges
on the drugs and and the guns
um the other part of this
is that
oh man I totally blanked uh well here
did Scott McFarland um says they're
hearing a tweet with this picture that I
showed yeah yeah he says state of New
Mexico will seek pre-trial detention in
the case of Solomon Pena he'll be held
pending court hearings and higher level
Court in the coming weeks so they're
they're just detaining him they're using
a pre-trial type detention right
um oh I remember now okay so not only
are they most likely gonna they're gonna
throw the proverbial book at this guy
okay they they I don't think they're
going to hold back they're gonna be like
yeah this was attempted murder he had
intent to harm them he wanted them to go
earlier in the night to make sure that
people were up he wanted them to shoot
lower he was upset that they were
shooting at the ceilings and up up in
the uh upper areas of the dwellings of
the homes he was upset about that he
wanted harm to be done
so I would assume an attempted murder
charge would be passed along these four
people for sure
the other thing is that from what I
understand there's also
um
the potential because he he already had
19 felony charges that he went to prison
for almost seven years on okay remember
the smash and grab schemes that the that
he was you know he basically he would
steal a car and then drive it into a
store and then he would steal the items
from that store
it from what I understand those charges
can be used against him in this case to
show a pattern now there's
the whole idea like
if he was like I don't know arrested and
put in jail for like having a couple
ounces of weed right
that would be something that would be
irrelevant and you'd be like Ah that's
that's that's actually
um
that's actually uh not that could not be
used right you couldn't be like oh well
he's a career criminal he did this right
you would have to you would actually
have to compare these two situations say
oh you know what there's actually
prejudice against him if you're trying
to use this like marijuana charge right
or like some other dumb trivial thing
that he went to jail for however if you
then said hey this guy
was on probation until 2021 after he got
a jail in 2016 and was there it was in
jail or in prison from 2009 to 2016 and
once he got out he was on probation and
as soon as he got lifted from probation
he announced that he was running and
then after he lost the race he then went
and committed these crimes and intent
intend to to intimidate or attempted
murder whatever it might be
those charges from what I understand can
be used against him
to prove that this guy has a criminal
violent past
and serve time for these different
things for these different charges
larceny burglary uh putting a a a a
delinquency and there's a couple other
one I know and receiving stolen property
basically those charges it wouldn't it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be uh something
that they would just dismiss they could
actually use that in the case as saying
that is actually relevant to the history
and behavior of Salomon Pena and so
that's the potential that they throw
that in there and say look he just got
out of prison well five years ago six
years ago was on probation and then
immediately went back into crimes
immediately went back into intimidation
immediately back went back into uh
committing something that he obviously
shouldn't and and wouldn't be able to do
so
and the reason and I saw I see Captain
terp here said felonies prevent you or
should prevent you from holding office
obviously in this situation what
happened was Miguel Garcia the incumbent
Democrat who was his opponent in the
race tried to challenge the candidacy of
Solomon Pena but the judge at the time
said nope he was given the right to vote
in 2021 in April after his uh
so then they said because of that
there's nothing against me holding him
against office obviously interp I don't
know if you know this but there's
members of Congress that are felons yeah
a lot of them no there's a lot there's a
lot of people like we said yesterday
people can be reformed felons totally
fine obviously in some of these
situations like Solomon Pena and I would
even say some of the city and
congressmen out there uh commit crimes
they do their time they get out of doing
their time whatever might be and they
commit crimes again you know well I mean
there's a difference and and you know
this has been the huge debate on the War
on Drugs right is that uh non-violent
crimes
um someone who commits violent crime is
uh less likely to quote unquote be
reformed they can be I'm not saying they
can't be but a violent crime is a big
red flag right a non-violent felony is
is something completely different but I
want to show you Gabe Sanchez a video
that um
and cheds of tick tock I believe is the
Twitter account that the post of this
video they found us on Tic Tac and this
is exactly the reason why uh people like
Pena and others and the people in the
Insurrection the guy who showed up with
was it Cincinnati they showed up at the
FBI location with the [ __ ] nail gun
nail gun all kinds of all these crazy
bastards are everywhere they showed up
to Nancy Pelosi's house with a hammer
they tried to uh kidnap Gretchen Whitmer
like that's the unfortunate reality we
live in right and this is the delusion
that Pena this is some of the delusional
[ __ ] opinion was believing but listen to
this guy here and see if you can make
sense of anything the [ __ ] that he's
saying this was this was just over a
week ago he's I think it's January 10th
is the day he's talking about if you can
make any [ __ ] sense of this listen
you remember that one time on January 10
2023 when Biden signed our Sovereign
rights away
when he made Canada and America and
Mexico won and we finally understood why
the borders were wide open and being
invaded and nobody gave a [ __ ] okay
first off what are we talking about I I
don't know but first off I want to point
out his little camouflage um
sweater here more hoodie whatever it is
does this does his nipples Have Eyes is
that
I it's a wolf right I know but yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're they in
their eyes are placed they're brighter
maybe maybe he can peel it down and the
nipples exposed kind of like you know
like a nipple ring cover maybe maybe
it's you know jewelry kind of thing you
can could be you know milk them here's a
here's the craziest part
I I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about with January 10th and some
sort of Biden science okay I don't know
this is there some trade thing that
happened I don't know listen this would
only assume that this guy really
believes this is the problem that this
is the real problem we have Gabe Sanchez
is this guy believes that the present
has the power
to to take away our sovereignty with the
stroke of a pin and combine Canada and
Mexico together oh I know okay I just
looked it up
but this guy this is why this is why
these people have trouble
when Trump was in office and now that
he's at office with all his nonsense and
what he's going to do and what he can
and can't do is they don't understand
that the president does not have this
power that you're saying the President
should not be authoritarian number one
and really honestly we should rein back
the presidential office in my opinion
we should give a lot more power back to
Congress because we have more control
over Congress what I mean by that is we
get to reelect them every two years we
can [ __ ] fire them if they don't do
their jobs like we'll do in 2024. but
this guy clearly didn't understand it um
is this the thing he's talking about
here yeah so for for anyone who's
wondering what he's talking about is on
January 10 2023 there was a a
declaration of North America oh my God
wait no no declaration are you serious
you know what kind of ramifications that
has on hours that is a sovereign oh my
God so basically you know an agreement
that's between Biden president obrador
of Mexico and prime minister Trudeau of
Canada they went to this North American
leader Summit and they basically like
Hey how do we help improve security
Prosperity sustainability inclusiveness
across these six pillars so wait a
second what you're saying what you're
saying is is the three presidents did a
photo op to sign a piece of paper to
have an agreement that they probably
already have that what you're saying
possibly or at least or at least put
down on paper to be like how do we you
know because they cover diversity Equity
inclusion climate change environment you
know what's crazy about this is these
people think Joe Biden can't put on his
[ __ ] tennis shoes and [ __ ] and he
doesn't know where he's at and stuff
yeah but somehow this guy's figured out
a [ __ ] way to combine Canada and
Mexico but listen this this gets crazier
and you know what [ __ ] it if they want
to combine I'd say [ __ ] it do it yeah do
it no borders no borders right but
here's the thing
this gets crazier this is not the
craziest thing that this guy says listen
to this [ __ ] he claims that you're not
gonna have water and food and [ __ ] I
think angelism
yeah it's weird now our money is
worthless our country is poor
we have no food or water
we're living I want to point out this
guy looks like he's not missed a meal by
the way yeah this guy has this guy has
plenty of food plenty of Twinkies plenty
of food I'm sure he took a snack just
before he made this video right and
we'll have a snack after he's done right
let's let's let's keep going because I'm
telling you it it even gets crazier I
know it's you're you're saying Tony
there's no way this guy is can get more
delusional but yes yes yes they can
living like
people didn't
Venezuela and Cuba it's weird because
they came over here to escape that but
we just turned into that it was kind of
like all those books that warned us like
Marxism yeah but we didn't read those or
we did we just didn't care and then we
saw it happening and we all told each
other about it and we said Hey look it's
happening but then we all went to work
for Corporate America just so we could
fill their pockets to pay for our [ __ ]
that we didn't own anyway oh my God he
runs he runs straight into it he runs
straight into the argument he just made
the argument yes for socialism right
also it makes it seem like he read uh
Marx's book like he read about Marxism
in a book he's like some of us he's like
man we didn't read it some of us did
like is he trying to Humble brag that he
reads don't like no and then he and then
he says and then he says uh we need to
get rid of capitalism basically yeah
Okay let's listen to the Dismount listen
to the Dismount yeah that was crazy back
then wasn't it
that was crazy back then what
what oh uh like okay hold on this guy
comes out and says this declaration of
North America which is obviously helping
the press all these different six
pillars that they talked about all it is
is just it's just a public statement
from the three presidents saying they're
partnering in this effort that's all it
is it's nothing crazy right it's there's
not there's not even an executive order
it's just like Hey we're agreeing that
there's a public partnership that's it
it's it's not it's not like the borders
have just like I mean there's no border
in Canada but it's not like the border
wall or anything to like all of a sudden
dissolved though it is obviously because
it's Trump's border wall it's falling
over because it's literally going over
it's rusting it's falling apart and now
we have to repair it because that's how
cheap Trump is but it's not like these
borders just like dissolved right it's
not like we went back to what America or
North America was like before we came
over to colonize it and steal it and and
fight over it
uh
I say well first off I say no borders I
think borders are the problem in terms
of what border walls and that type of
[ __ ] right stigmatize and villainize
people it's terrible but this guy over
here makes the case
for socialism it's Insanity by saying
that we're just in a [ __ ] Rat Race
and we're working for capitalism but
that's why I keep saying to the audience
that messaging matters narrative matters
this guy truly does like socialism he
just doesn't know what it is right he
has no clue he doesn't know he's a
[ __ ] bonehead he's ignorant okay but
this is a type of ignorance that that
Stokes stochastic terrorism it it gets
people like Pena to believe these
delusional lies and do what he did this
is all [ __ ] terrorism on our on the
truth it's terrorism it's true terrorism
for crying out loud it's Insanity that
this guy read something on Facebook that
now now the three countries are combined
you know what we should do real quick
before we leave we should we should ask
Wordsmith here is it Mex Americana all
right okay
um how would you you're gonna you know
like gonna benefit you know
um right right right right well you
gotta go from the
from the north of the summer maybe can
Americano Karen Monica yeah okay can
Americano okay I feel like right okay
let's see can
um
Mexico caramel I don't know can't I
don't know but I feel like because
because you in case it Blends in right
you have Canada Mexico
America and uh yeah and I think if you
take his like Canada can lead into
America so can uh mayor and then
instead of the Ika it goes yeah Eco so
can America Robbie's got it yeah
Robbie's got it there you go oh my God
but this is the delusion that we're
talking about
this is the and I keep telling you that
if we get a national narrative we get a
national message that we can speak to
these people and tell them hey man you
just you just don't want to go broke
because of a medical bill right you
don't want education to constant arm and
a leg right so you have to pay it off
your entire life you don't want a decent
[ __ ] wage you don't want corporations
bending you over not using the Vaseline
right those sorts of things like
regulation and [ __ ] like that those
sorts of things safety nets social
safety nets so that you know you can
secure your you know economic status
those sorts of things we agree with them
on they just don't know it they're
deluded by the fact that uh Jew Badness
parted the commodity sucking babies
blood and he's combining Mexico and
Canada they're [ __ ] and having a baby
and it's called Can America yeah or just
North America you know I don't know
either one it is
when the zombies [ __ ] come for us
guys borders won't matter okay that is
that is the name of it really is
we're gonna call it something new
something fresh oh that's what we do
here on the Tony Michaels podcast we
Rebrand we re-message and we redo the
narrative so that you can go out into
the world and save democracy
you gotta Follow You Gotta follow this
show why aren't you following this show
on YouTube go subscribe right now to
this show because you're gonna you're
gonna get to vote later today on the
bonehead of the week on YouTube If you
subscribe to YouTube you go to the
community tab the um the poll will be
right there and you can actually on
YouTube
I don't know if you know this you can
there's no time limit like when I post
on YouTube you can just keep voting and
voting you can change the outcome and
you can time travel and change the
outcome of the previous boneheads by
doing that possibly We're Not Gonna
We're Not Gonna yeah we have widespread
voter fraud Tony to make that happen
stop the count okay we've stepped down
but but tonight we will not stop the
count the vote count will be on you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and me and Gabe Sanchez were bigger
now tomorrow Friday every Friday in the
second hour of the show also you can
follow at Tony Michael's pot and vote
there on Twitter as well as long as that
son of a [ __ ] is still running yeah
you're I hear it's on duct tape and
bailing twine at this point uh download
every single episode for us please if
you would on Apple Spotify Google your
favorite directory make sure to leave us
a great review while you're there thanks
for joining us today same time same
place tomorrow Friday's bonan of the
week until then serves that
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon